[Music]
ah The
Simpsons celebrate good times it's the
25th anniversary of America's yellowest
family and in our minds out of the
seemingly endless cast of characters on
the show there's one we'd love to
interview most of all that would be
Diamond Joe Quimby he's what you'd call
a politician's politician so we put
together an homage to the real mayor of
America over the course of a quarter
century the most successful American
public figures of the modern era have
visited the humble town of Springfield
but as exemplars of political guile
resilience and sheer Charisma all of
them pale beside Springfield's own
commander and chief mayor Quimby the
illiterate tax cheating wife swapping
pot spoking spendo crat Diamond Drew
quinby hey I am no longer illiterate
Joseph Fitzgerald om Ali Fitzpatrick rck
odonnell The Edge Diamond Joe Quimby was
elected mayor of Springfield in
1986 his campaign ads are legendary for
their succinct persuasive Force Quimby
if you were running for May he'd vote
for you whether he's been caught cutting
deals with the kingpins of organized
crime they're milking rats milking rat
rats I'm outraged you promise me dog
orya or engaging in embezzlement so
Brazen it would make Bernie maid off
blush we will now hear suggestions for
the dispersement of the $2 million don't
you mean $3
million of course and when it looks like
he's finally done for good and the
results are in for sicho Bob 100% for
Joe Quimby 1% and we remind you there is
a 1% margin of error Diamond Joe Quimby
always manages somehow to hang on he is
the real Come Back Kid the mayor's
office is not for
sale God bless you mayor Quimby you've
got our vote vote Quimby